well
[Music]
How are you greetings by Cristián Cáceres with
his brief Spanish neon news bulletin
for today, Friday, March 5, in
Cuesten Ser and legislators debate a
plan to help tenants
facing evictions due to the
pandemic. This plan requires
landlords to notify them  your tenants
with more time in advance before
removing them from the house this time
will be determined depending on the
contract of each one the second part of
this plan will consist of a
cut stamp if an emergency issue arises
due to the pandemic and
listen to this  the johnson johnson vaccine
is now available here in southern
nevada this unlike the others
consists of a single
dose supplies can be in
warm temperatures and last longer
outside than modern vaccines and
expert fans say there is no data to
show that  certain groups should get
one shot over the other and
nascar weekend at the motor speedway of
las vegas' more than 12 thousand fans will
attend this event which makes it one of the
biggest in almost a year
normally the venue has
enough space for 80,000 people but
this time it won't be possible due
to health and safety however not  it's
expensive and the respite mode and they say it
will be a great show for all the
fans and now we move on with
the weather forecast we will have a
pretty sunny day with temperatures
reaching 70 degrees we will see some
breezes by Saturday and temperatures will drop
for next week  I'm
Cristian Cásseres with your
news now news preview in Spanish Happy
Friday
[Music]